welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
for more than 10 years we've been
hearing that highlander was going to get
a reboot
ryan reynolds was signed on actually
signed on the dotted line
until he pulled out probably because
deadpool got green lit
oh
oh hello
i know right
whose balls did i have to fondle to get
my very own movie i can't tell you but
it does rhyme with pulverine
every couple of years we hear new rumors
about somebody else's sign an article
through this movie but there are very
strong rumors
that henry cavill superman is taking on
the role
he is going to be conor mcleod of the
clan mcleod this is still just a rumor
at the moment but there is a director
there are writers
and this has been at least a decade in
the making
and i would say
brilliant to be honest this is a
franchise that needs a reboot it needs a
complete modern rework
[Music]
i feel her come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
there are a lot of other movies that get
this treatment that don't need it
um i've said in other videos johnny depp
as willy wonka
still causes me pain
i mean physical pain
i would rather put both fingers in both
eyes and twirl them around then watch
that film again
it was badly done and it was an absolute
[ __ ] show from beginning to end
and it didn't need to be made because
the original was so beautifully done
gene wilder is willy wonka
count to three
come with me
and you'll be
in a world of pure imagination
and you'll see
into your imagination
there was no reason to ever redo that
film
but the highlander franchise
other than the fact that it was
completely ruined by multiple sequels
the tv show though was actually quite
good i quite enjoyed the tv show
i wish raven had gone on a bit longer
but anyway
um it was kind of ruined by multiple
sequels that highlander 2 was just awful
shoehorn and sean connery back into that
film was just ridiculous
but the basic premise of the film was
brilliant and i would love to see a
modern
twist on it you cannot die mcleod
accept it
and particularly with modern special
effects things you know it's that sort
of genre is very popular at the moment i
completely believe that this film will
be great and henry cavill will be
brilliant in it
he's already done all the swordplay
training so may as well
but who would you like to see in the
other roles
several people have been connected over
the years and i actually think they've
got a bit of a trick here they could
pull with a ramirez character
tonight you sleep in hell
there can be only one
[Music]
now
this is going to be a bit left field
but i think the character should be a
woman
um i don't see any reason why it
couldn't be i know you're gonna say
ghostbusters
when they did the reboot with just women
in that was awful but that wasn't awful
because it was women it was awful
because it was awful
i actually suspect the new ghostbusters
movie is going to be incredible
um there are women in that
the character of ramirez though could
very easily be a woman
and that can actually really add some
theater and drama to the film
when kurgan then kills her the ramirez
character is like a father figure to
connor
tell me how did it happen for god's sake
why does the sun come up
or are the stars just pinholes in the
curtain of night
who knows
what's worse than losing a father though
it's losing a mother
when i thought about this my initial
instinct was antonio banderas
would be genius from the original film
obviously you've got an egyptian with a
great scottish accent and a scotsman
with a brilliant french accent there's
always a bit confusing
why not have somebody that actually kind
of looks a bit like i know antonio
banderas is spanish but that actually
kind of looks like you come from
mediterranean
they can actually sort of do an accent
that would work for the character so
yeah my initial thought at tony banderas
but then
why not have a woman why not have
somebody like selma hayek for the same
reason that antonio banderas would work
salma hayer could work and she'd bring a
bit of sex appeal to the series
but really who i want to see is michelle
yeah
now
obviously from crouching tiger hidden
dragons fame
[Applause]
[Music]
she is a great swordsman
she is a brilliant martial artist and
she moves in the most beautiful way
she's currently appearing in star trek
discovery
and she is brilliant in that
so i would love
and if the directors or the producers
ever watch this video they won't but if
they do
really consider michelle for this role
she'd be fantastic
that brings one with the kurg on
who the hell do you cast in that role
because it has to be somebody that's a
monster
david bautista has been put forward for
this
his role as the destroyer
has been fantastic and you can
completely see that that would work but
he has
officially turned down the role
there are lots of other actors there
that could appear in this and
none of them will ever be quite as
brilliant as the original
[Music]
lots of names have been connected to it
nobody official yet
but if they get that right
because
any good any good sci-fi or action movie
needs a great bad guy
so his role almost is
as important
and i say this though henry cavill has
not actually been officially
signed on and also it's not official
what party's going to play we're
assuming it's going to be conor but he
could just as easily be ramirez or
the kurgan but there is one thing that
is vital if a highlander movie does
return
we need some queen music on there
it won't be highly do without it
so let's see what happens let's see what
gets officially announced in the coming
months but i'm really hopeful and really
looking forward to a highlander remake
it's actually a remake i want to see for
once
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
thanks very much if you are new to the
channel please like and subscribe hit
that bell notification really helps us
out and then leave a comment
if they do have a high-end movie
who do you want to see appear is the
kurgan and ramirez
[Music]
you